if all the devils are chained during the
month of Ramadan how come people
continue to commit
sins and I do agree with you this is a
common question and I remember several
years back when I was in school and when
I heard this Hadith that the devils are
chain in the month of Ramadan
immediately the question that came to my
mind and the question that comes to many
Muslims mind and many non-muslims is
that if the devils are Chang
then how do people how do human beings
yet commit
sins this question is based on the
Hadith of Mami wasallam which I
mentioned earlier a Hadith
of
Ahmed volume number two page number 230
Hadith number
7,148 which is also repeated
in chapter number five Hadith number
21106 where where the Beloved Prophet
said that o people the Blessed month of
Ramadan is
approaching and Allah has ordained for
you that you fast in this
month and the Gates of Heaven will be
open in this month and the Gates of Hell
will be closed and the Devils will be
chained in this month is a
night which is better than a thousand
months and a person who's deprived of
the blessing in this month is truly a
deprived person now when we give this
Hadith it clearly mentions that in this
month of Ramadan the Devils will be
chained answer The Logical question if
devils are chained then how do human
beings yet commit
sins to make the people understand we
have to realize that when the devils are
chained it does not mean that the devils
are slain they have been killed they're
yet present but they chained they're not
killed the power is yet there but it is
diminished for a better understanding I
like to give you an
example that when there is a lion or a
tiger who is free there are high chances
that he may kill you your life is in
danger but the moment that tiger or that
lion is Chained you are
safe you are safe as long as you
maintain a safe
distance after the Tiger has been
chained if you come too close to him
there are chances yet you can be killed
so as long as you maintain the distance
from the tiger who is Chained you are
safe similarly in the month of Ramadan
if you maintain a safe distance from the
Satan you'll be saved and if you read
the Quran Allah says in Surah Bak chap 2
verse number 168 be care careful of the
toan of the footsteps of the devil for
he is to you an a enemy many places
Allah subhana tal says in the Quran that
be careful of the footsteps of the devil
Allah doesn't say that be careful of the
devil because a normal Muslim an average
Muslim who has average IM when he sees
the devil in front of him he will be
careful for
example Suppose there a young girl who
comes to
an average Muslim a young boy who has
average IM if a young girl comes and
tells him that let's spend the night
together that Muslim will say spending
the night together with a girl is Haram
it is Zena he will immediately object
but that same girl if that girl phones
that young boy and speaks to him on the
phone the boy will say speaking to a
girl on the phone there's no problem so
he speaks to the girl for a few times on
the phone for a few minutes later on the
girl says let's go and have some snacks
in McDonald's on Ki Fried Chicken having
snacks for a few minutes for half an
hour with a girl in McDonald's no
problem so he goes and has snacks with
the girl in McDonald's later on the girl
says why not have dinner in a restaurant
having dinner with a girl in restaurant
for a couple of first no problem then
the girl says why not spend the night
together and then the boy says spending
the night together with the girl no
problem so this
is footsteps of the devil this is not
mentioned in the Quran this is just my
own example so what Allah warns us is
that be careful of
the the footsteps of the devil if the
Devil comes directly in front of an
average Muslim who has IM he will
abstain he will run away from it but
thean are the things which are
dangerous so what we have to realize
when the devil is
Chained his footsteps are
restricted so many of the sins are
prevented but if we go close to him then
the chances that we'll be overtaken by
the devil and commit a sin are very high
so what we have to be careful that in
Ramadan if we keep the distance then the
chance of committing sin is less but if
we go close to the Satan even though
he's chained like how a tiger can walk
even after he's chained same the devil
so this is my understanding the Bel
Prophet said the devils are chain the
devil canot move but left distance so if
we keep the distance we'll be safe the
second reason that I feel is that in the
month of Ramadan though the devils are
chained we fail to realize that the
balance 11 months they are free and the
impact that that the devil has on the
human beings for these 11 months it
leaves those impact that impression in
the month of Ramadan to give a better
understanding I always give the
example that there are drug pedlers
which try and get customers the
youngsters from the colleges from the
universities so what they do initially
they give the drug free and they entice
the youngsters for having drug
later on after some time they charge a
nominal amount for that drug later on
they charge an exorbitant amount but by
the time the youngster is already hooked
on to the
drug so even if the drug dealer is not
there they will try and find where the
drug dealer is they will go out of the
way to find him and get the
drug and many of them even if the drug
pedler the drug dealer is imprisoned by
by the law they will go out of the way
to find someone else they may go in a
chemist shop and buy mandri whatever it
is they are so much hooked on to it so
these people who have become
addicts to drugs or rather say addicted
to the Satan even though the Satan is
imprisoned the effect is yet there so in
this way we understand as a drug dealer
as a drug pedler even after he goes the
drug addict gets accustomed to that drug
so we human beings we accustomed to to
the sin and even though the Satan is
imprisoned we keep on committing these
mistakes but mainly those people who
have become addicts fall in this
category so those who do major sin fall
in this category but the normal Muslims
the average Muslims who haven't become
addicted it's easy for them to stay away
from
sin and the third reason that I
give
is that though there are some Scholars
who say that in this month of Ramadan
the strong
Devils the marids they imprisoned the
smaller ones are free so they keep on
committing mistakes but my
understanding the third reason
is
that though the devils are chained by
Allah subhana wa taala they can yet
whisper and one of the ways the Devils
try and get the human beings close to
them is by whispering
and Allah says in the Quran in Sur Nas
chapter number
114 verse number 1
to6 they whisper in the hearts of the
human beings and they withdraw among
them the Jin and Men it's talking about
the satans talking about the Devils who
whisper into the hearts of the human
being and and the withdraw and among
these devils are the Jin and the human
beings so maybe Allah subhana wa ta'ala
has imprisoned the Devils who are the
Gin but the human beings V are yet free
so one category of devils that the Gins
have been in prison but the Satan are
even amongst the men that's what Allah
says who are yet free and yet we have to
be careful of The Whisper Of The Devil
the wasasa this wasasa mainly
is thing that attracts toward the sin
the sin they had committed but the
chances are less and furthermore it's
clearly mentioned the full Hadith that
Allah has ordained for you in this month
of Ramadan that you should
fast only if you fast according to me
will the Devils be imprison that's
talking about the Devils that are going
to attract you so Allah says if you fast
Allah has ordained for you fast Ing and
the Devils will be put in Chains so the
Devils that after you if you fast surely
they'll be restricted the criteria for
us to be away from the Devil is to fast
if you fast with the proper
Nia seeing the of Allah subhana wa tala
surely the devil will not be able to
entice you and the best logical way to
prove this is if we check the crime rate
of the Muslim countries during Ramadan
it goes down but if you check the crime
rate of the non-muslim countries in
Ramadan it is the same the reason is
that because they are not fasting the
non-muslims this devil yet has an effect
on
them because the Muslims are
fasting if not all properly at least
majority or at least quite a large
number so because of that the crime rate
in the Muslim country country then the
month of Ramadan is low as compared to
the other months but the crime rate in
the non-muslim country is approximately
the same indicating otherwise even the
non-muslims they will not commit any
sins the criteria is that you have to
fast properly for the sake of Allah
subhana wa tala